we have a voicemail number it is two one
nine to david p let's take a listen to
this voicemail you know the only silver
lining i can find and the illegitimate
president Trump is you guys to have an
easier time getting donations so we'll
free speech TV or more left-leaning
organization sexually how it goes on the
right some power yes mart not to go that
well I don't know yet that messy only
silver lining you have yeah they can't
scare me because last time we had an
illegitimate president since can govern
give you more on 911 happen yeah well
that's a whole other set of concerns no
doubt but yeah I mean I think people are
recognizing because of not only Donald
Trump winning but also because of the
threats Donald Trump is made about suing
media outlets what was I punch my mic is
I'm so agitated about this it um I think
people are recognizing the importance of
financially supporting independent media
that's a good thing on the bonus show
today an app that will tell you if
Trump's tweets are costing you cash
based on the stocks that you own that
plummet when Trump tweets also can
virtual reality make you more empathetic
and we will talk about a notable website
shutting down its adult services ad we
will find out if anybody on the show has
ever used those back pages of a number
of different magazines but also what it
means for business david pakman.com
slash membership sign up and get instant
access to the bonus show